it's time for et social study your quick  look at what the stars are posting  online I'm just so excited Reese  Witherspoon turned 41 earlier this week  and check out the celebratory pic she  posted Thursday night with her two  oldest kids Ava and deacon she captioned  it there's nothing better than  celebrating my birthday with my  wonderful kids  hashtag proud mom and seriously a 17  year old Ava looks just like her mama  I'm so lucky to be a Victoria Beckham  posted a pic of her daughter Harper on  Friday to honor Red Nose Day we're  loving this shot of the five year old  rocking some adorable braids I feel very  lucky and incredibly blessed and keeping  with the family theme Chrissy Teigen  shared of this hilarious  behind-the-scenes clip to Instagram from  her new smirnoff campaign with a her mom  [Music]  oh hell yeah  Chrissy your sauce  [Music]